nous allons nous faire passer pour
responsable d'un centre de formation
français qui recherchent un centre
d'appels
nous avons rendez vous avec une
plateforme téléphonique qui va vite nous
encourager arnaquer les clients
[Musique]
on a appris cette semaine que sylvie
tellier laisser sa place à cindy fabre
pour le voilà être la directrice du
concours miss france vous auriez pu
postuler en rien du tout non non
sincèrement non non mais en toute
franchise parce que j'aime toujours ce
côté de miss france ce côté le show
payet conte de fées j'aime pas être dans
l'organisation et les en inde et en fait
au quotidien
on est plus libre
nous lui présentons les tarifs de nos
formations mais ils nous incitent à les
augmenter au delà du raisonnable pensez
à faire une chanson pour à peu près 25
heures
[Musique]
les contrefaçons le sont beaucoup plus
chers pour le faire
/
j'ai 49 ans 49 49 ans
ces vieux est squatté thème à pied
tenues trop moto je suis venu en
trottinette électrique hu
alors parce que je suis écologique et
surtout parce que j'ai plus de permis de
conduire
alors c'est pour ça que je me balade en
trottinette selon lui les instituts de
formation gonflent les prix lorsqu'ils
sont sur la plateforme du cpf
son nom
sans façon
karsenty vendre un max douleur leur
contenant 60
[Musique]
une voiture bagis changer un téléphone
mais parce qu'il était cassé je pouvais
plus l'utiliser mais sinon sinon je les
ai mis dans la banque je continue à
acheter des bouquins et d
aider vous voyez tellement je suis
stressée je sais même plus ce que je
veux dire qu'est-ce que je peux faire
pour vous déstresser basso faire sortir
les gens s'il vous plaît oui alors on va
y aller alors on va commencer par le
premier rang là haut tout doucement et
apparemment les clients français ne sont
pas très regardants sur les prix
[Musique]
les centres de formation peuvent ainsi
gagner des fortunes il nous met alors en
garde ne pas faire trop d'argent sinon
les contrôles tombe j'ai besoin
de six mois que j'ai pas pris de
vacances
j'en ai plein rendement d'employeurs
dans le juge et l'assassin
je peux pas aller à l'encontre de sa
décision
dix jours
et
hop en une minute nous voilà avec quinze
jours d'arrêt de travail c'est djibo mis
à compiler les équipements de luxe les
plus modernes il est entièrement
automatisé
jusqu'aux toilettes
elles sont équipées de capteurs de
mouvements ça s'allume quand vous
rentrez même pas besoin de toucher la
cuvette on va bouger avant ce pompier ça
souffle tout seul
c'est le luxe absolu on ne trouve pas ça
partout
le motif nous le découvrons enfin de
consultation
[Musique]
après une rapide recherche nous
comprenons pourquoi il a inscrit
troubles anxio-dépressifs
pour cette pathologie et l'assurance
maladie préconise 14 jours d'arrêt
max va offrir un beau d'avant-bras à la
science il a des poils blancs et des
poils bras
ça va chauffer un peu à tout à
ça sent le poulet grillé
pour voir de toutes les couleurs
souffrir
soupir c'est bon je sais pas si vous
avez vu mais j'ai
j'ai pris également un rendez-vous à
11h15 pour ma femme je vais savoir si
éventuellement vous pouviez également
lui donner quelques jours d'arrêt de
travail
j'aimerais bien pouvoir partir avec elle
quelques jours quoi
fatigue ou je sais pas vous mais ali
fatima hassan et hussein
le tableau date d'il ya 300 ans mais
c'est la première fois que je vois une
représentation de la famille du prophète
en général c'était interdit en islam les
icônes religieuses la représentation du
prophète c'est interdit
vous avez un père et une mère et étienne
fortin vous avez une photo d'eux eux ce
sont mes parents donc je garde une image
deux et dix minutes plus tard
bah oui enfin c'est surtout voilà pour
pour l'accompagner un peu dans là dedans
a
souvent dit c'était mieux avant pas
toujours ouais c'est pas si mal
maintenant ce sera la phrase optimiste
de ces indemnisations